[Music]
I'm going to this is my attention
control his elbow and now I have his
Center but in my Center and he's pushed
my Center down to the ground his elbow
out pop everything in place project his
weight down second one I'm gonna control
his elbow by bringing it up and in and
put his weight on to me pushes me down
[Music]
he's here I'll bring him unto me in the
next one
I bring his elbow in front of him he
seen and now it pushes directly on his
Center so bring his elbow in front of
him then I move my Center pushing it
down take all the slack out push it down
[Music]
by manipulating the elbow I can create a
relationship in my favor
[Music]
don't lose that center-to-center
connection it's still there
still there
still there don't do this
keep the extension of the technique
every pin has a Naga in it
it just looks like it's this
it's not you can't come towards me come
towards you you can and I can project
okay